all right so Steve says book five has my
head spinning a bit going back to
chapter one was Aristotle saying that if
you're deficient in any other virtues
you're also guilty of the vice of
Injustice no he's a he's not saying that
um so to begin with let's make a couple
distinctions deficient in a virtue
doesn't mean that you're vicious it
means that you're in between Vice and
virtue right you lack the virtue it
would be better for you to have the
virtue
but you're not necessarily at The Other
Extreme
and
um you don't have to have every single
one of the virtues in order to be just
in relation to other people with respect
to a virtue right you could be
courageous but not temperate or you
could be witty but not uh truthful and
you're you know it's not an All or
Nothing kind of affair right that would
be more like the stoics or at least the
stoics in theory because in practice
this All or Nothing kind of thing is
very very tough to to apply it um tends
to demoralize people more than inform
them so
oh here we go so George says this notion
of dessert with Aristotle is interesting
does he mean that given a certain
standard to equalize both parties of
exchange you give people what they
deserve and this standard is based
either on Democrats aristocracy Etc so
the standard depending on what we're
talking about could be based on the
political form right but it doesn't have
to be so when we're thinking about the
marketplace that may be totally
independent of whether you're in a
democracy an oligarchy a tyranny
whatever
um that has more to do with like who has
political office who gets to hold
positions who gets to serve on juries
for those of us in America uh we you
know often try to get out of jury duty
uh for the ancient Greeks it was a great
thing to be able to serve on a jury
right
um so there has to be some sort of
standard if we're going to talk about
um
proportionality people often don't agree
on which standard ought to be applied
now so Allison has a great question here
does it follow that Aristotle would not
see a pacifist as being just if they are
not abiding the law and refuse to join
up to fight for their country uh yes
Aristotle would say that if you are the
kind of person who should be fighting
for your country that
um refusing to do so would be being
unjust and this is a great example you
might be violating the law right but
you're also leaving your country people
in the Lurch you're avoiding dangers
that some other poor bastard is going to
have to take on in your place
and you're also being a coward so you're
being a coward not just in relation to
you but in relation to others perhaps
the people that you should be protecting
the other person whose Place uh who the
other person has to step into your place
and uh take on the dangers so now
Aristotle would say of course
who he has to serve
um it's not slaves it's not women it's
not children it's not resident aliens
like himself
um it's people who are full citizens
right and if you're too poor to afford
armor
um you know maybe you can be uh in the
light infantry
um but you're definitely not going to be
out there on the battlefield as a
hoplite because every hoplite had to
supply his own weapons and armor right
so it's kind of a very small restricted
set of the citizenry but if you're in
that Bunch yes Allison
um Aristotle would say if you're like oh
no I'm a pacifist I'm not going to hurt
anybody you're actually doing wrong
which we might find
um you know jars with our conception of
like conscientious observers in places
where we do have people who are allowed
not to serve in the military
um very often they have to do some other
kind of service as a substitute for that
right or they might for example like
many people who were pacifists in World
War One or World War II serve instead of
being like Battlefield soldiers be
Battlefield ambulance drivers or Medics
or something like that so there's a lot
of different ways to to go about this
right
um and we might extend this this is a
great question because we might extend
this to other things that people try to
avoid leaving other people in the Lurch
and I'll bring up a very interesting uh
example I don't want to take too much
time but my mother's family the lemuries
is got into the United States because of
the institution during the the American
Civil War of higher soldiering which
meant that if you got drafted and you
had money you could pay somebody else to
take your place my great great
grandfather father was one of those guys
he crossed the border into Vermont where
a doctor had his son who had been
conscripted and four or five hundred
dollars which was a ton of money at that
time uh took his place didn't get killed
settled down in New England eventually
the family moved to Chicago
um
now
would that be just Aristotle would say
yes and the reason he would say yes is
because the monetary exchange if the
doctor's son had tricked him into taking
his place or the doctor's son had simply
said I'm not serving you are going to
serve in my place then it would have
been unjust so kind of interesting how
these things work let's take Allison's
example of a pacifist who says I'm not
going to go serve out there on the
battlefield
um Equity might say Okay
um we'll let you do that strictly
speaking the law says that we ought to
um beat the crap out of you maybe whip
you a bit and throw you in prison for a
while and take away your goods we're not
going to do that instead we're going to
let you you're not gonna
fight but we'll let you build galleys
right or we'll let you cook food for the
soldiers or do something along those
lines
oh we got a good uh question here from
from uh Nicole similar to Allison's
point but this assumes that the war is
just and the people above are good for
example citizens who refuse to conduct
human atrocities would be just
so yes and no Aristotle is not assuming
that the war is just
um he's saying that you have to serve in
the war and he's not particularly
concerned whether the war is just or
whether the people above are good you
can still behave justly in an unjust War
right you can serve as you're supposed
to serve you can protect your comrades
you can keep the enemy from retaliating
against you
now citizens who refuse to conduct
atrocities would be just yes and you
could do that even in a just War right a
war so I mean this is a big topic right
there's an entire field out there called
just War theory that makes a number of
different distinctions like you know is
the cause for war just is the conduct of
the war just and you can be in an unjust
war and behave justly you can be in a
just war and behave unjustly as well so
there's not a neat coincidence between
those things
Allison says up until fairly recently
blasphemy was a crime here in Ireland
written into the Constitution so some
viewers were calling for Stephen Fry to
be prosecuted because he said on TV that
he didn't believe in God
that's a curious one because merely
saying that you don't believe in God
to me doesn't rise to the level of
blasphemy right blasphemy is when you're
saying stuff that's clearly derogatory
about God you know like God sucks maybe
that could be very very mild blasphemy
right or blasphemy could also be
speaking
um uh facetiously about religious things
you know the um the French Canadians by
the way are very well known for engaging
in blasphemy in their swearing you know
they say yes which means chalice or
tabernac which means Tabernacle right
and these are swear words sort of like
you know [ __ ] and damn here in English
right
um imagine that somebody uh okay so
Allison says he he did say he didn't
believe because God caused the suffering
in the world it still doesn't strike me
as blasphemy uh sounds like a
um giving a claim and giving an argument
for that claim um but I'm sure there's
some some you know people who wanted to
have him uh prosecuted for blasphemy
because they've got a super super wide
range of this and this is where we got
to think about like the application of a
law right uh we're going to talk about
this a little bit later
sometimes laws can be set up poorly as
Aristotle mentioned and then we have to
think about well when would when did we
apply these what do they apply to how
should the penalty uh you know work in
these sort of cases so
justice so David says
do a lot of our favorite stories if not
most play out Aristotle's use of the
distinction between the just versus the
unjust Robin Hood is a good one Robin
Hood for those who are maybe not
familiar with it is a noble guy who robs
the rich and benefits the poor as a
result using their very money what would
Aristotle make of Robin Hood
um
you know just robbing the rich per se
I don't think Aristotle will be cool
with that I think he'd say you need to
rob the evil rich in order for it to
have some some uh possibility but doing
Justice right
um things going back to David's
questions
um a lot of our favorite stories play
out Aristotle's use of the distinctions
and its distinctions plural because
notice we've got a lot of different
kinds of Justice between the just and
the unjust I mean I don't know that a
lot of our stories necessarily reference
Aristotle and they may in fact be
um kind of mixed up about what Justice
is in a way that Aristotle could perhaps
inform them I will say that a lot of the
conflicts in good narratives are often
driven by people
being confused about what's just or
unjust and then misinterpreting each
other and viewing the others more unjust
than they are this is what allows to set
up big conflicts right
empirically so Equity is a case-by-case
kind of thing
um Nicole says with Caesar Crossing the
Rubicon be an example of this I I don't
think so uh that's that's a deliberate
you know choice on his part it's not
really a uh matter of the law I mean you
could say he was he was told to
um comply with the dictates of the
Senate he chose not to thereby starting
what he knew would be a Civil War I mean
I don't think you can
Equity is something that you don't apply
to yourself you apply it to other people
you know
um so Caesar satisfying his own desire
to remain in power by
you know effectively declaring war on on
the Roman people in the Senate that
doesn't really strike me as Equitable
um he was supposed to have been somebody
who is fairly forgiving
um I mean you could look at his
proposal to extend amnesty to Cato who
killed himself rather than allow that to
be the case
as perhaps a case of equity
but Crossing the Rubicon I I don't
really think so
um Nicole says a thief who is broke
commits less Injustice than a thief who
likes stealing for the sake of stealing
he said no it depends on how we're
looking at it if we're looking at it in
terms of those four things that I I said
um yeah I mean Aristotle would also say
why is this thief broke is that their
own damn fault you know uh that's very
different than somebody who is tricked
into losing their life savings or who
exists in a country where hyperinflation
like in Argentina destroyed people's
life savings several times
um
and something similar is happening in
Turkey too right so yeah Aristotle would
make a distinction between those those
sorts of things
George says if I had a friend who told
me that they were a vegan and we decided
to buy lunch together and they asked me
to give them vegan food but I
deliberately decided to give them food I
normally eat which is not vegan they
call me out on it I decide to downplay
their concerns am I acting in an unjust
manner yeah I think you are you know I
think this case illustrates an
inconsiderate person what would
Aristotle say
um yeah I mean you're
I think you're acting in in an unjust
manner not least because as we pointed
out um when we're talking about
um the social virtues in the last
session Aristotle says that telling
people truth not just about yourself and
your accomplishments but in general is a
matter of Justice right so lying to
somebody who has some pretty strongly
held principled ethical beliefs about
you know not creating or not or about
minimizing animal cruelty by living a
plant-based lifestyle
um yeah I think that that that could be
Injustice right
um and you could ask what's your motive
were you like this
freaking vegans they're such a hassle
you know so hard to to
um appease right uh you know they're
gonna worry in this restaurant whether
there's like a drop of bacon fat or a
bit of honey in it or something like
that that's one thing going about it and
saying I'm gonna trick the vegan because
I hate veganism that would be that'd be
a very different disposition I think
right so yeah
um and then there could be something
lighter where you're like oh I just
forgot you know
um I didn't I didn't realize you know
they they bring this thing and you both
eat it and you're like oh this is really
tasty and then the waiter is like um
yeah you know the the Bacon fat in that
is the special ingredient you're like oh
I didn't know right that would be that'd
be a very different kind of uh
disposition at play so so those are good
questions